looks like the trailer just dropped
forever owns least anticipated
spider-man related film by Sony with a
black protagonist symbiote lives matter
man if this movie gets less than 99
percent on Rotten Tomatoes the critics
must hate Clint are anyway let's get
into it I really love venom ever since I
first read his comics as a little kid
lethal protector was such an important
story to me that I made my parents hunt
down all of the five Venom's action
figures available on eBay I still have
them on a shelf above my bed they came
with this little slimy toy thing in the
box that that dick Calvin lost at my
eighth birthday party if someone finds
this rubber symbiote head toy please
email me I miss it very much and as a
huge venom fan I think Tom Hardy is
great casting for Eddie Brock he was
wise to hold off from being the oh so
memorable character Rick Flagg so he
could be a leading man however I'm sure
a lot of people are disappointed because
he's been fan cast as every other white
male comic character but as it is I'm
very happy with him as venom much better
choice than that other skinny cracker I
sure do love me some classic Eddie Brock
venom stories and so far this movie has
me at a solid yeah I know everyone else
has already sold on hating it like
there's absolutely no way they'll come
back on it but I can be won over if you
surf the web you'll find a lot of people
have made up their minds already
unfortunately this could be the best
superhero movie of all time and I can
still tell you with confidence the box
office numbers won't impress
however since everyone else is already
pissed off I will offer an opposing
viewpoint and will say it's well it's
not garbage yet for the moment it's
pretty damn obvious Sony rushed this
thing out the door giving it it only
come out 12 days after filming wrapped
I bet the actual character model for
venom is still just a wireframe and the
effects team is trying to figure out how
to get that tongue to move properly you
know that really boring side of
filmmaking no one ever talks about I
think a lot of people getting pissed off
you need to chill out though it's a
teaser trailer the point is to tease you
then again just one shot of the title
character would have been nice
Sony if you don't have anything ready
for a trailer just don't do one we can
wait what is even happening in this shot
does venom have telekinesis now I bet
this shot if it appears in the movie at
all is going to be some gratuitous CGI
of symbiote tendrils pulling these
monitors off tables as venom or some
other symbiote character swings past and
kicks this dude in the face that's
what's brilliant about the Deadpool
movie marketing you don't need any of
the effects ready you just put Ryan
Reynolds in the suit and have him ad-lib
a bunch of dumb crap and film it on your
iPhone and it's ready to post the VFX
team can take all the time they want
with that one without having venom
himself in it let's take a look at what
we do have in this teaser we got Tom
Hardy Boys as mopey walking around the
city man and unfortunately isn't dressed
up as a 40 year old skateboarder and
hanging out with a bunch of inner-city
kids in some earlier set photos we saw
him with a pen and notebook looking
rather repor --is-- then in a later one
he's dressed as if he was a soldier not
sure if they're going the classic route
or doing an agent venom thing if I were
to make a really baseless guess it's a
scene where the symbiote is trying to
help him sneak past some guards in shape
ships his clothes come back in October
and tell me if I was right boy I hope he
gets his fancy winter jacket at some
point we see Eddie's wife and Wayne who
doesn't have short hair zero out of ten
cancel the movie not comic accurate
enough wait Michelle Williams has short
hair for real they put a wig on her what
the hell is going on we see our
antagonist businessman a guy who works
for the Life Foundation opening a truck
to look at the suit while five
researchers stand behind him looking
bored part of me wants to jump to
conclusions about there being five of
them and say maybe we'd be getting the
five Venom's but in the book those guys
are all military trained these all look
like a bunch of nerds and the ratio of
men to women is off so who knows maybe
it's not an intentional thing and I'm
grasping at straws for something to be
excited about we also see Eddie as
laying in an MRI machine man this
trailer is pretty devoid of Easter eggs
like can we just get something that
looks familiar
maybe a hint on the computer screen that
he has like a rare type of cancer that
makes him an ideal host for the suit
rather than most people or like a
recognizable name drop something
anything
I guess the overall look of the trailer
seems about right
director Paul Rubens said he wanted to
look of the film to be inspired by
Cronenberg and John Carpenter and I
think that's a great choice so it looks
kind of horror movie ish and dark venom
solo stories work well when they play up
the horror and sci-fi elements like in
venom The Hunger which is arguably the
best venom solo story with Eddie Brock
from the 90s I really recommend reading
that one since it feels like a
Cronenberg or carpenter story directors
and Studios have talked about the
concept of creating a horror movie mixed
with a superhero film for a long time
and I think Venom's a way better use of
that than in Fantastic Four though if
this fails we still got new mutants
which is doing that creepy demon bear
story arc a pretty big topic of
discussion is how exactly this thing
will work without the involvement of
spider-man Tom has reportedly been seen
on set with Tom but not in the costume
this is of course very confusing after
all all the times we've been given
conflicting information and then there
is that cringey interview with Amy
Pascal where Kevin Feige clearly
fantasized about stabbing her to death
so that is a chance Ted and Tom Holland
a Spider Man will pop up somewhere oh
she's a special kind of person I've
known to say Tom Hollands spider-man
won't be a factor for two reasons one he
was on the set of Suicide Squad and he
wasn't in that movie actors visit each
other sets for fun it's what they do -
spider-man homecoming is really toned
down most of the time and feels like a
Disney Channel version a spider-man and
leading that into this movie about a
space alien that eats human brains which
you know serves as an allegory for drug
abuse be a little weird especially
considering how young Tom Holland is
still I don't think this version of
spider-man is emotionally ready for this
[ __ ] man
although on the other hand if they're
pulling a fast one on us and it is in
the MCU infinity war has Spidey going to
in a suit with a giant spider logo on
the chest maybe he comes across some
black goo during his adventure and sheds
it in between movies I'm kind of hoping
for that because Venom's character is
dramatically less interesting without
spider-man as a part of his origin
without that element of being a dark
reflection of Spidey or having a lust
for revenge he has no conflict his inner
turmoil then becomes struggling with
whether or not he wants to eat people
and that's hardly is interesting when
compared with this antihero that
considers Spider Man a villain without
that piece of the story he's a reporter
who gets bonded with an alien and then
fights crime and sometimes eats people's
brains that sounds a lot less cool to me
beyond that the character skin looks
like Spider Man
it's gonna be weird when this space
alien inexplicably forms a giant spider
logo on eddies chest with no reasoning
for it or when he shoots webs out of his
hands you could technically remove those
parts of the character and have him be
more like ultimate venom but that's a
lot more boring and forgettable in that
case he looks like a big black goo
monster with white eyes and not a
supervillain version of spider-man which
is what he's supposed to be could always
just slap a big V on his chest and do
like like a Superman joke about it on my
planet the V stands for if that's the
case I'll make Nightwing jokes forever
in terms of the story
lethal protector is a good choice for
inspiration it's Venom's first story
where he finds his footing as a solo
character and fights threats that aren't
nerdy photographers honestly a Spidey
connection is only necessary at the
beginning of the movie like it could
seriously just be a light cameo or a
reference to off-screen events Spidey
doesn't do a whole lot in lethal
protector they just tossed him in there
for fear of venom solo book not selling
it's like how I keep putting him in the
video thumbnails so people will watch
them I mean it's a real simple rewrite
to have Eddie fight and kill the 5 him
themes himself and yes I think the five
deadly venoms 1978 should be the
antagonists and not carnage there's like
no room for carnage in this story he's a
good second or third movie villain
I know it's breaking canon to have him
come after these guys but they have way
less going on story-wise they're not the
important nemesis characters you can get
rid of them real quick and then develop
Cletus for something more complicated
later you know in the in the sequel that
this movie won't have because everyone's
already made up their mind and won't see
it plus it would be really fun to see
these five Schmucks since they're the
coolest thing in that comic run that's
right I'm not very impressed by the
guardsmen sorry to all you guardsmen
fans out there I know there are a lot of
you prediction time maybe that's a
spaceship there or a shuttle from space
land Eddie goes somewhere he shouldn't
because he's an ace reporter man and
wants to get the inside scoop then gets
an alien STD and his ex-wife will be a
boring character and get no development
and only serve as a way of establishing
that Eddie isn't gay and then she'll
tell him that he should seek help and
stop being a weird half alien psycho and
he'll be all like my gift my curse [ __ ]
and walk out on it then she'll be she
venom for one scene in the sequel they
won't make maybe they'll blow their
symbiote load early and tie it into
Planet of the symbiotes were ship full
of them lands and just takes over the
whole city that would be pretty stupid
but hey can't have a superhero movie
without an end of the world scenario to
fight off I don't know I'm not 100%
ready to just hate it because I've been
surprised in the past when I thought I'd
hate a movie and sometimes I've been
disappointed when I get too excited for
one but with this I have a deeper love
and connection to the character than
most these other films coming out I want
this one to succeed because Venom's been
one of my favorites since I was just
learning to talk I don't wish this would
fail right out of the gate it's a shame
that a lot of people aren't willing to
give it a chance all I'm saying is yes
Sony has a bad track record
yes it's an underwhelming ass teaser but
don't sign the movies death certificate
just yet ironically I think this movie
is a sign of the times the superhero
genre is changing again and I
feeling its going to start looking a lot
like how it did circa 2003 ish it was
the Wild West of superhero films every
studio was green lighting every movie
for everything and continuity wasn't
even a twinkle and Kevin Feige zai yet
soon we're getting a spawn movie movies
based on Rob Liefeld books a spin-off
Joker movie set in the 80s and a bunch
other random crap only one camp seems to
be able to pull off the cinematic
universe ideas successfully so all the
competition is going back to green
lighting all kinds of weird random stuff
it's exciting to see what we could
possibly be getting an adaptation of now
since everything is fair game let's just
pray that this one doesn't become this
year's Fant 4 stick maybe it can lead to
a new era where a dumb comic no one's
ever read like Moon Knight can get a
movie adaptation without it being all
bogged down by interlinking with 400
movies and having a tone similar to them
maybe this could be the next big step or
it'll fall flat and Disney will continue
making a [ __ ] zillion dollars
[Music]
[Music]